I remember watching numbers and I
remember thinking I could never do this
I could never play this part I could
never I the words he's saying the amount
of dialogue he has I came up with a plan
but it it wasn't a plan that everybody
liked I will say that okay so I was like
I went to the producers and I said the
the the genius of the character is
catching up with the capabilities of the
actor and I was like and I don't want
you guys to like rewrite anything
because I'm stupid you know I want you
to have to do that I said and here's the
deal I'm going to come in not knowing
him and they were like what and I was
like I'm going to come in not knowing my
lines and they were not happy with that
lines fck and and so that's how we did
it for six years and what was great
about it was you're watching me kind of
get it as I'm getting as I'm performing
and it looks like to the audience the
audience sees a mathematician coming up
with the ideas